you and we'll have such great chemistry
yeah man together and it just seems like
a natural it's one of those movies where
you see the poster yeah and you think
all right these two guys hilariously
funny I want to see that I want to know
what guys together first of all that's
what I thought when I saw the poster
even though I was in the poster I want
to see this yeah I like these guys I
want to see what happened what's gonna
happen in this film I completely know
what's gonna happen but I still thought
like this is gonna be something cool you
know what it is man will first of all
amazing guy I can say in the top two
most amazing people that I've ever had
the opportunity to work with thank you
thank you very much no yeah yeah I got
what you're saying top two people you've
worked with not
[Applause]
well I'll take it
you took it yeah just took it I normally
took it I made it I know he's saying
I'll do it man just down to earth
everyday shows up to work with the most
amazing attitude just fun to be around
cheap as hell though one of the most one
that one is Dean oh my god will doesn't
I don't think we'll have spent the penny
I don't think he's spent anything from
like the money that he's made he hears
the first Blackberry ever and for me
wait he's still using up the first black
bear I'm not talking about a newer black
the first one and it's like taped up
he's like yeah he's like they'll never
get me oh you're afraid of a little
crank on his fingers are too big for the
buttons is like as weird it looks like a
dog ate it he was like but guess what
they'll never get me does he spend on
cuz you know it's funny cuz the times
I've been around him it feels like he
doesn't spend a lot on clothes no no not
at all
and the top two worst dresses I've ever
met in my life we'll definitely the
horrible dresses he's he's all it's all
you know what this like I call it grab
bag grab bag style like when you go
places and you give free bags and they
got t-shirts in it well that's a free
t-shirt yep that's what he says every
day yeah as you spend money on like
shoes sneak anything no nothing right
I'm the only dumbass that spends all his
money on clothes I'm gonna be broken
alright knowing y'all gonna look up I
can't always look good you always look
good you always put together I love
clothes I love clothes you know what's
bad though there's nothing worse than
then putting on an expensive outfit and
nobody notices that hurts your feelings
because for some reason when you put on
something expensive you step outside you
expect people to go that's expensive
they don't they don't know they don't
know never gotten one of them got one
nobody has ever done you're wearing a
leather jacket with like a tiger on the
back ever and no one says anything I
tell you the funny one I was on tour I
brought this leather jacket and it had a
peace sign on the back of it it was like
a rhinestone peace sign I said you know
what I'm doing the end of my show I'm
gonna turn around show the back of my
jacket and put up a peace sign the crowd
gonna go off I did it nobody said
nothing likes war was like what's that
on his back other didn't I try to show
y'all I think about fuel crossing yeah
sometimes getting no laughs is much
funnier than getting the last o for you
cuz you understand but you know what do
you mean for me no no no
before you go you know that's that's all
you got
I know what you're saying you know what
you're saying I was a genuine lamb
because I've never mean it like that
okay there's no genuine laugh in here
this show oh no no no no I got it
you